Hello, everybody.
This is Dr. Maria
Plummer. Sorry about the
delay. This is our
first pathology lecture.
We're going to
discuss cellular
adaptation and cellular
injury and cell death.
These are the session
objectives that should
be the same in your
CPG. And these are the
general topics that
we will be hitting on.
Okay,
I do realize that the
histology as a subject
has been reduced in
most medical schools.
And I want to start
out by saying that one
thing important
about pathology is to
know how the abnormal
looks from the normal.
Having said that, I
do realize that this
is your first year,
first semester. So you
still need to know
about the epithelium,
like where it is,
what it is, and stuff
like that. But I bring
you these pictures
to remind you hopefully
you've had some of
this and also I want to
make it clear that in
your first semester
first year I generally
do not I can't say
always but generally do
not put pictures on
an exam for first year
first semester medical
student it's not time
yet I believe to do it
afterwards in second
semester and then in
your second year but the
boards do do pictures
and I don't believe in
just putting a picture
and telling you to
to recognize that you
can't do that but I do
want to remind you about
the types of epithelial
tissues here. The
one especially we're
going to talk about
later will be the one on
the bottom in the left
stratified squamous
esophagus and the one
over on the bottom right
the pseudostratified
columnar. As you can
tell in the stratified
squamous it's usually
the esophagus it's a
protective epithelium
and for the pseudostratified
columnar that's
the trachea where you
have cilia and that
helps with it taking out
pollutants and things
like that but they're
all kind of important
the thing is that just
realize that there
are different types and
I don't mean for you
to recognize it but
you do want to see it
when we look side by
side so pathology is the
study of the structural
biochemical and
functional changes in
cells uh tissues and organs
underlying disease and
that That is a direct
definition from my
particular Bible, which
is Robins and Cotron,
pathological basis of
disease. They just came
out with a new issue
this year. So a lot
of this is from that.
General pathology versus
systemic pathology
just means that what
we're going to talk
about the next few
lectures is general
pathology. The groundwork
basically that is very
important, though
it's not as exciting I
think anyway as the
systemic pathology which
discusses the different
organ systems.
Okay, but no matter what
general or systemic,
we want to in
pathology we want to
think about etiology
which is the
cause of a disease,
the pathogenesis,
the changes, the
morphological
changes that
are associated,
and the clinical
manifestations.
This is a really good
overall picture from
the text which shows
the normal cell all the
way on the top and
generally the first part
of this lecture we're
going to talk about
adaptation which is all
the way to the left.
When there's a
stressor just like
human being cells
need to adapt. If
you can't adapt it
will be a problem.
So we're going to talk
about the cellular
adaptations first
however if there's
an inability to adapt
for whatever reason
or if the stimulus
is very injurious
there's going to be
injury and then And
there is a matter
of time whether that
injury is reversible
or irreversible.
And irreversible
injury can usually
lead to necrosis,
but we're also
going to talk
about another type
of cell death
called apoptosis.
Okay, so let's
start with the first
adaptation is hypertrophy,
which is an increase
in the size of cells
that, of course,
the organ is going to
get increased. Please
note that in
hypertrophy there are no
new cells. it's the
size that's increased.
In hypertrophy you have
increased production
of protein in the
cells because growth
factors are activated
and also because
of mechanical force
and now you'll see
what I mean in a second
that stimulate the
protein pathways to
protein synthesis.
Now hypertrophy
like a lot of
adaptations has two
types physiologic
and pathologic and
physiologic means
basically normal increased
functional demands
stimulation by growth
factors or hormones
and examples are better
to define this which
means things like
uterine growth during
pregnancy skeletal
muscle in response to you
know working out so your
bodybuilding those are
physiological hypertrophy
they're supposed
to happen they're
supposed to happen there's
nothing wrong with
that pathologic would
mean it has to do with
a disease so the heart
and hypertension the
blood pressure is elevated
if it's elevated
the heart is working
against the vasculature
and it has to pump
harder and so it's a
muscle and it's going to
increase in size by
increasing the cell size
that would also happen
in something like
aortic stenosis where
you have the aortic
bowel which leads out
from the left ventricle
that is narrow and
the blood has to the
heart has to work
hard to push out the
blood. Same thing it's
going to work hard and
like skeletal muscle
it will hypertrophy.
So this is a picture
granted it's from a
mouse but this is
myocardial. I don't expect
you to identify this
because again you
may recognize that
this is a cardiac
muscle or not. The
point being that on the
left is normal, the
right is hypertrophy.
It's hypertrophy
because the cells, this
is a longitudinal
section, are thicker,
they're bigger, even
the nuclei are bigger.
So this is hypertrophy
and it's the result
of cellular protein
production increase.
A lot of ways
that can happen is
mechanical sensors
will detect increased
load like the heart
filling or heart
pumping or your
pumping iron. Sensors
will activate
signaling pathways.
I don't need
you to memorize
these pathways
you probably learn
about them in
other lectures.
Some other signaling
pathways will be
increased production
of growth factors and
even vasoactive
agents. So basically
what we need is activation
of transcription
factors which is
increase the expression
of genes, and that
in the case of
muscle will encode
contractile proteins.
What I just said is
illustrated, if you're
much more of an
image person, I do
this a lot. I will talk
it through and then
I'll give you the
image. This is directly
from the book, this
is exactly what I
just said, probably
a few things added
here. I don't need
you to memorize this
particular figure,
but you should look at
it and understand
it, what's going on.
So let's start with,
let's go to another
adaptation i'm going
to give you two cases
i'm going to talk about
it this is a 70 year
old man who complains
of difficulty urinating
is a weak urinary
system and um has to
get a lot of times
in the night that's
called bacteria to go
to go urinary his PSA
the prostate specific
antigen is mildly
elevated and as you as
you may or may not know
PSA can be elevated in
benign and malignant
processes of the
prostate. He undergoes
a transurethal resection
of this prostate.
Okay and what do they
find now again now
we're going to look at
tissue. Okay so on the
bottom with the blue
box is normal prostate
and on the top left
of the two boxes is a
lower power and a higher
power view of this
man's prostate. So you
have to ask yourself
okay again what type
of epithelium is
present this is glandular
or columnar epithelium
okay it's not squamous
it's not transitional
it's glandular um and
that's what because
remember prostate
secretes things um is
there an increase in
the number of cells and
the answer to that is
going to be yes and
what do we call this
adaptation and you'll
i will reveal that in a
second after i present
the next case which
is a 45 year old
woman who is pale and weak
and she has a decrease
from her red blood
cell count she has
anemia but her bone
marrow biopsy shows an
increase in red blood
cell precursor cells so
that indicates an
attempt to compensate for
the decrease in the
rbcs and this is what
it looks like on the
top again i don't expect
you to recognize this
on the top is normal
bone marrow with all
the three lineages
if you remember um
the the rbcs the white
cells the platelets and
on the bottom although
that's a much more
magnified picture those
that's a bone marrow
of this woman who has
uh increased erythroid
precursors I do not
expect you to recognize
that what you see
in um the middle here
I mean in the lower
left is a large cell
that's a megakaryocyte
and all the really
dark almost black but
they're really kind
of blue black uh cells
are erythroid
precursors so you're not
supposed to have this
many okay and and and
i gave you a question
i would say there
would be increased
irregular precursors i
don't necessarily need
you to identify them
not at this point yet
so what process is
going on here in the
bone marrow and also
in that man with
the prostate and the
answer is you can stop
the tape if you want
but it's hyperplasia a
bone marrow undergoes
rapid hyperplasia
because it's responding
to the deficiency
in red blood cells.
So if there's any
acute bleeding or
hemolysis, there's
feedback loops and there's
a growth factor slash
hormone or erythopoietin
that's activated
from the kidney
and it stimulates the
growth of red cell
progenitors and allows
the red cell production
to increase. So
that's a good thing
because it's a
compensatory thing and it's
more. So what is
this hyperplasia? It
means an increased
number of cells, okay?
Hypertrophy is increased
size, hyperplasia
increased number and
it's usually in response
to something a stimulus
and it can only
happen in tissues if
they're capable of
dividing and i'll get
into that in a little
bit now some organs some
tissue types um will
have both hyperplasia
and hypertrophy but
that does not happen
in permanent tissue
which we'll discuss in
a second hyperplasia
is the result of
growth factor driven
proliferation of cells
mature cells but sometimes
it's also increased
output of new cells
from tissue stem cells
there are two types
like in hypertrophy
there's physiologic or
pathologic physiologic
usually is due to
hormones growth factors
when they're needed
to increase the function
of hormone sensitive
organs or when you
need a compensatory
increase because of
damage so one of the
two of the best um
examples would be the
breast at puberty the
uterus at pregnancy even
the breasts at pregnancy
where the uterus
of pregnancy would
grow probably a little
bit of both but the
point is that the puberty
breast is increasing
the number of cells
not necessarily the
size although both can
happen that's normal
that's supposed to
happen your breasts are
supposed to come out
of puberty and in
pregnancy they get bigger
because of the increase
in mother's milk
pathologically what
could it mean well there
are things like
endometrial hyperplasia
which means that the
lining of the uterus is
going to be thicker
and that should not
happen so it's response
it's an inappropriate
or excessive hormonal
situation BPH which
is what the gentleman
had the first case
benign prostatic hyperplasia
means there's more
um cells present now
hyperplasia is not in
and of itself cancer
it's not even really
pre-cancer you can't
really call it that
however and I want you
to realize this increased
cell division that
you know you're
dividing the cells there's
more cells coming and
that means there's
an increased risk of
getting genetic
aberrations because and if
that happens you can that
can drive proliferation
that's unrestrained
and give rise to
cancer so it's not
cancer but hyperplasia
needs to be taken care
of okay here is a picture
of a heart obviously
um cross-section on
the left is a cellular
adaptation not now
we're not looking at
micros we're looking
at gross pictures and
that's a hypertrophy
of the heart and as
compared to the normal
heart and I know that's
a little bit smaller
in the picture but the
heart left ventricle
shouldn't be more than
1.5 centimeters so
whatever this person
has is causing left
ventricular hypertrophy
now why is this called
hypertrophy and why
is the heart not going
to have hyperplasia
and that goes back to
what I was talking
about that permanent
tissue for our intents
and purposes permanent
tissue includes cardiac
muscle, skeletal
muscle, and nerve tissue
because those generally
do not regenerate.
Now I know that there
are new things coming
out and they're
regenerating nerve tissue
etc but for our purposes
for traditional
definitions of tissue
these three especially
are permanent tissue
and we'll talk more about
that in healing
and repair.
So let's go on to
another case we've got
a 70 year old woman
this time who has a
hysterectomy because
she has benign smooth
muscle tumors which
are known as myomyoma
also fibroids the
uterus is small and it
has no other visible
pathology or as we say
gross pathology in
processing the uterus
they take a sample of
the endometrium and
what do they see
they see this on the
left hand side with
the blue arrow this
again is glandular
epithelium that should
be columnar uh it's
not squamous um and
it does that because
the you know the
endometrial lining
secretes things and also
it gets sloughed off
when menstruation
now whether this is
physiologically pathologic
it can be kind of
debated this is a
woman who know what is
postmenopausal so she
is normally would not
have um hormone uh
secretion that would
make her that would um
increase the lining of
the uterus because she
cannot get pregnant
anymore on the right
you see the normal
and I think what you
notice is that I hope
that and again it's a
different stain I
realize that and that's
because a lot is I showed
you because a lot of
different stains look
at different color
actually it's the same
stain but it looks
different because of
the characteristic of
the picture on the
right the normal shows a
lot more round tubular
structures or glands
than the left okay so
what do we call this
adaptation this is
called atrophy it's a
reduction in the size
due to a decrease in
the cell size and
number because there's
decreased protein
synthesis and increased
protein degradation like
the others there could
be physiologic or
pathologic uh normal
development um sometimes
uh you get atrophy
and the uterus postpartum
you want it to go
back down you want the
um the uh the uterus
to be back to normal
so that's atrophy but
pathologic um there's
a lot of reasons for
pathologic astrophobia
and that includes
a decreased workload
you're not using your
muscles so you just
use atrophy deneration
uh decreased blood
supply because that
supplies oxygen if you
don't get oxygen the the
tissue cannot grow
or cannot you know be
fed decrease nutrition
in general and decrease
hormone stimulation
also pressure you
can get pressure atrophy
something if you have
a tumor that's benign
but it's huge and
it's pressing upon some
other internal organ
it can that organ can
become atrophic okay
so that's atrophy and
what happens is in
atrophy there's trophic
signals that are
reduced and it's the
opposite of hypertrophy
so you get a decrease
in protein synthesis
how does this happen
they talk about the
ubiquitin proteasome
pathway that's where
most of the that's
how degradation of the
proteins happen in the
cell they have these
things called these
enzymes the ubiquitin
ligases are activated
by disuse and
nutritional deficits and
the ligases will attach
to this ubiquitin
and I'm sorry the
ligases will attach
ubiquitin to the proteins
targeting them and
and they're being
targeted for degradation
in the proteasomes.
A lot of times we'll
talk about this a little
bit later atrophy can
be accompanied with
autophagy which is
basically a cell that's
starving eats itself
because to decrease
nutrient demands okay
so now this is a really
important concept
we're going to go into
this is the last of
the adaptations i'm
going to talk about
which is metaplasia oh i
said that already all
right well this is a
little bit harder this
this um this case 52
year old man presents
with a six month
history of heartburn last
year he had reflux uh
diagnosed with reflux
esophagitis that
means that acid was
going back into esophagus
from the stomach and
that of course causes
feelings of heartburn
and things like that
they do an endoscopy
and there's an
irregular g-e junction
we really don't
want to have an
irregular g-e junction
but there's no
masses so there's no
cancer okay so again
on the left side
of this photo is
stratified squamous
that is the normal
epithelium of the
esophagus why i alluded
to this earlier and
this is because the
stratified squamous
is protective when
the bolus of food
comes down from the
mouth to the stomach.
On the right hand
side however this is
like the G-junction
but there's something
abnormal about
it. Although this
glandular epithelium,
those are columnar
cells, they've also
got big nuisance vacals
in them, some areas
that look pale.
That's called
intestinalization. It almost
looks like intestinal
rather than stomach.
So we have two types
of epithelium and what
is going on here and
it's going on right
near the junction I
think there's a long
thin arrow though it's
not as good but that's
kind of where the
junction and this is a
very important process
called metaplasia.
Metaplasia is
reversible I do want
to emphasize that
and it means that
there's one
differentiated cell type
that was replaced
by another one
why would that
happen again this is
adaptive one cell type
is sensitive to some
stress is replaced
by another one that's
better able to
withstand the stress so
in the case of the
esophagus getting acid
reflux the although
the stratified
squamous is protective
it's not protective
enough but by causing
the cells to turn
into an intestinal
cell or producing mucin
the mucin will buffer
or neutralize the
acid and that's how
it protects itself
but and this is the
big but even though
it's reversible
it if it keeps if
the stimulus keeps
there you can get
to dysplasia and
then cancer and so
metaplasia is
important to remember
the most common
metaplasia most common
tissue type is columnar
disquamous but there's
a lot of others and
I have a table later
to show you results
this results from
either reprogramming
of stem cells that
are local or colonization
by different cell
populations from sites
that are adjacent
and like a lot of things
i've been mentioning
it's stimulated by
signals that are
generated by growth
factors cytokines etc
so again i don't
expect you to know this
uh by just looking at
this is metoplastic
bronchoepithelium what
is normal is the question
now if you remember
or maybe you did
not get this yet the
bronchial epithelium the
upper respiratory tract
has as I mentioned
a little bit earlier
pseudo stratified
columnar epithelium with
cilia I don't see any
cilia here and this does
this looks stratified
but it's not columnar
it's actually
squamous so this is a
columnar epithelium having
gone to squamous why
would it do this in
the trachea in the
bronchus oh the upper
bronchi because if
you're a ****** the smoke
is going to irritate the
mucosa and it's going
to become metaplastic
and the squamous in
this case is more
protective okay this is
smoke that's an irritant
not acid that that
needs to be neutralized
this is another case
which is kind of
interesting again I don't
I hope maybe you
can see that this is
squamous epithelium and
I do have the keratin
labeled but the point
is this is a bladder
and if you remember bladder
should be transitional
epithelium
transitional epithelium
you can go back and stop
the tape and go back
to what it's supposed
to look like it it's
it's transitions it
changes because the
bladder has to go is
distended or it shrinks
depending on how much
urine you have in it so
this case the transitional
epithelium has
has become metaplastic
to squamous
why would that happen
there's two main
reasons but there
could be a lot of
other reasons but
one is bladder stones
if you have stones
in your bladder
and they're not
coming out and they're
irritating the transitional
mucosa again it will
become squamous with
keratin because it needs
to protect that mucosa
another thing is
certain infections with
schistosoma in certain
parts of the world
can lead to this as
well again the metaplasia
is adaptive this is
uh the endocervical and
the ectocervical area
and this is important
there's a transformation
zone where it's
supposed to go from
columnar on the left to
squamous on the right
but in the transformation
zone that's where
you go to get in the
pap smears they try
to get cells from there
that's where cancer
can start and that
can cancer can start
there because metaprasia
starts there okay
so in this case the
squamous metaprasia um
where the blue arrows
are and that is
protective uh among other
things as a woman uh
ages there's ph
changes there might be
infections they have
babies things like that
so as time goes on
uh this might happen
squamous metaplasia is
kind of normal here but
you want to make sure
that's why women get
pap smears every
year that it does not
become dysplasia or
become cancer so this is
a picture of metaplasia
of columnar to
squamous epithelium i'm
repeating myself i do
that a lot just to
make it stick and so
you see on the top the
cartoon and you see
on the bottom what it
really looks like from
columnar to squamous.
I'm not really sure
where this is. It's
probably long, I'm not
sure, but that's not
the point. The point
is you've got two types
of epithelium, and
it's changing because
it needs to adapt.
This is a nice table
to keep in mind,
and we went through
all these already.
Cigarette smoke can
cause menoplasia
in the upper
respiratory tract, to
squamous epithelium,
the bladder stone,
the Barrett's
esophagus, and the
******. So keep
this table in mind.
I think it's
important, and it
can happen in
other tissue types.
So to review
the adaptations
they have
normal, atrophy,
hypertrophy,
and hyperplasia.
And there's a
cartoon here
and metaplasia
on the bottom.
Okay now let's go to
cell injury and there
are many ways cells
can be injured this is
just a few hypoxia
means decrease oxygen
usually via decreased
blood flow or anemia
physical things like trauma
radiation electricity
chemicals infections
with microbes like
bacteria fungi viruses
immunological reactions
all of this can cause
injury to cells to
tissue etc now this
slide i want you guys to
just look at and keep
going because this
is, I'm not going to
test you on this slide,
this is something
they put in the
book about what
happens to cells or
what happens in
response to injury.
Well there's, they
figured out between the
two editions, the one
five years ago now,
that there's three
different types of kind
of responses or
pathways, the integrated
stress response, the
unfolded protein response,
and autofagy. The
only one I really want
to talk about here
is autofagy because
that's, I mentioned
earlier is when the cell
eats its own contents
because its response
it could be response
to stress in a
physiological state like
aging or in pathology
like in hypoxia etc
and the whole thing is
the formation of this
autophagosome that's
a vesicle from the
isolation membrane which
is known as a phagophore
and that's where
all this organelles
and structures are
sequestered and And as
it matures, it's fused
with lysosomes, and
there's digestive enzymes
in there, and they
degrade it. So they
kill this out, and
that can be protective.
Okay, so let's talk about
cellular injury a
little bit more,
and reversible and
irreversible. This is
a 58-year-old man
who has a history of
unstable angina, who
presents shortness
of breath and chest
pain and sweating.
um the question is
that within 30 minutes
it could be 20 minutes
too uh what reversible
changes may take place
in the myocardial
area that's supplied
by the coronary artery
which is being occluded
by a thrombus so
it's telling you what's
happening here that
there's hypoxia because
the artery that's
supplying that area
is being blocked it
doesn't die right away
there's first there's
reversible change now
which one of these five
is reversible now of
course this is way I
introduce the subject
so unless you write
ahead you're not going
to know the answer.
The answer to this
is going to be
C as in Charlie
cellular swelling.
The others are not
reversible and we'll
talk about the
others especially the
first two in this
lecture and the last two
in the healing lecture.
So this is a picture
of kidney tubules.
Cellular swelling and
I want to make this
clear cellular swelling
is usually the earliest
manifestation of
cell injury at least
microscopically and you
can see vacuoles in the
cytoplasm and it's
also known as hydropic
change or vascular
degeneration also you'll
notice that it's a little
pinker theosinophilia
because this one in
this case is progressing
to acute tubular
necrosis of the kidney
but the swelling is
acute and reversible
to approximately 30
minutes now i mean it's
not exact it could
be 20 minutes 35
minutes the point is
it's a short period of
time which is why you
brush people to the
hospital they're having
a heart attack so
what's going on here
well in this case
ischemia there's a low
blood supply to the
kidney in this case
uh it causes with any
ischemia to any organ
causes decreased
oxidative phosphorylation
and therefore decreased
ATP so what's going
to happen well
you don't have energy
now ATP and that's
going to decrease the
function of the sodium
potassium pump so
what's going to happen
is you're going to
have influx of sodium
and water is going to
fall which means they're
going to have swelling
or edema now it
says influx of calcium
that comes later that
that's still that
would not be reversible
so i shouldn't really
put calcium in there
but the sodium and the
water are important.
So let's continue this
patient goes to the
hospital one hour after
he has the symptoms.
EKG shows that he's
having an MI and they
have myocardial enzymes
that you'll learn about
that are consistent
from the diagnosis and
this is what you can see
under that microscope
and I hope this
looks like a mess to
you because it looks
like a mess to me. It's
very disorganized and
the only thing really
you can see is these
dark cells and those are
basically dying nuclei
okay so the nuclei
become shrunken they're
dark that's pycnosis
there's also carrier
axis that's fragmentation
of the nucleus and
carrier lysis or
dissolution and those
are all greek terms and
within time you know
the nucleus is going to
be gone but it'll be
the tissue will be dead
before that okay but
the nucleus will then
should be gone and
we'll talk a little bit
more about that in
a bit so this is not
necessarily a this is
all what's going on okay
from from the the first
two okay the first
two bullet points are
going to be reversible
basically um you can have
oxypedic phosphorylation
decrease or damage
and decrease ATP
at first, which what
it will happen is, as I
mentioned, to reduce
the sodium potassium
bump, and you're going
to get cell swelling.
That's reversible.
But after some time, like
30 minutes, for example,
you'll get an
increase in anaerobic
glycolysis. And we'll
talk a little bit
more in detail about
this, which decreases
glycogen, and that
increases lactic
acid, and you get
decreased pH, and that
causes chromatin
in the DNA decline.
Protein synthesis is
going to be decreased.
The cell is dying and
the calcium pump is
important here because
calcium then enters the
cell and I have pictures
of this so don't
worry and causes activation
of a lot of different
enzymes listed here
and all those enzymes
do they break things
up and that's going
to cause membrane damage
and DNA damage etc.
And then finally as
everything gets destroyed
and there's digestion
of the cell uh the
contents will leak out
and elicit inflammation
which is the topic
of the next lecture
now this is not autophagy
because autophagy
is when the cell does
it to itself this is
because there's been
hypoxia or some kind
of injury so let's
talk a little bit more
in details about these
mechanisms of cell
death slash injury and
like it's a spectrum
you know i mean reversible
and irreversible
there's not one time
you know one minute
but it is notably around
30 minutes could be
less or more but
notably so we already
mentioned atp depletion
and what happens is
that the mitochondrial
membrane when the
atp gets depleted
forms a mitochondrial
permeability transition
pore when that pore
opens the there's a loss
of membrane potential
mitochondria and you
get the failure more
failure of oxidation
phosphorylation more
ATP depletion and
we've already talked
about the plasma
membrane energy dependent
sodium pump at the
sodium potassium pump and
that will cause reduced
so I mean reduces
the the action of that
pump and it causes
sodium to enter inside
the cell it shouldn't
be inside the cell
remember sodium is
usually out potassium
in and um accumulation
um of water by osmotic
drive okay because
water follows sodium
that's a big thing so
you get cell swelling
okay now i talked
to you know again you
don't have to read this
in detail the point
is that i mentioned
glycolysis um you know
because there's no
atp there's no energy
the body's going to want
to use like or the
cells are going to want
to use their glycogen
stores they're depleted
and when glycolysis
happens under anaerobic
conditions you get
lactic acid so that
will decrease the
intercellular ph which will
cause uh dna problems
um decrease activity
of the enzymes in the
cystus in the cell
itself but at this is
the point where things
become dangerously bad
and you're irreversible
damage and the
mitochondria the membranes
they're all dead and
that's necrosis we're
going to talk about
the calcium pump what
i did mention and that
contributes to necrosis
because it breaks
down a lot of things
the calcium is a secondary
messenger and also
we'll talk about the
last point which is
formation of a reaction
oxygen species which
can happen when you have
incomplete oxidative
phosphorylation so
that was mitochondrial
damage what about the
membrane of the cell
well if you're going
to lose the membrane
you have damage that's
going to affect a lot
of things the integrity
and the function
of the cell and again
it can be the result
and it usually is of
ATP depletion and the
calcium mediated activation
of phospholipases.
Remember what cell
membranes are made of.
Also, plasma membranes
can be damaged
directly from toxins
from bacteria or
viral proteins, etc,
etc. So it doesn't
always have to be
as a result of ATP
depletion, they could
be damaged directly
by things like
chemical, physical,
bacterial.
Reaction oxygen
species are oxygen free
radicals that cause injury
to cell membranes by
lipid peroxidation.
And when that happens
when there's membrane
of mitochondrial damage
we're going to have a
decrease in phospholipid
synthesis and
membrane damage and
increase in phospholipid
breakdown and basically
what's happening is
the calcium severe cell
injury is associated
with these degradation
because there's
activation of the calcium
dependent phospholite
bases because the
calcium has increased
and it's going to be a
secondary messenger
that does a lot of the
enzyme reactions we'll
talk about in a second
cytoskeletal filaments
kind of anchor
connect the plasma
membrane to the interior
so if they become
abnormal you're going
to get stretching and
and rupture and the
cell is dead again
this is a pictorial
image of what i just
said so if you prefer
the image you can
take a look at this
It basically said
what I just said,
it may have a few
extra things in it.
So just to mention,
again, this is one
other slide, which I'm
just giving you some
background information.
I'm not going to
test you on this, I'm
going to assume some
knowledge of it, but
I'm not going to ask
you for formulas or
anything like that.
Free radicals, as you
know, are unstable,
they decay spontaneously,
but normally cells
do have mechanisms
both enzymatic and non
-enzymatic to remove
the free radicals and a
couple of them include
antioxidants in the
the binding of iron
and copper to transport
proteins that's how
it protects itself and
enzymes that act as
radical scavenging systems
like the ones listed
catalase etc again
i just want to bring
that back into your
memory so this is a slide
that you can you know
i'm not putting on
any exam but somebody
else may you know and
this is a picture of
what i just said okay
so here's an image i
think it's helpful if
you want to take a look
at that i want to
bring back the calcium
problem because it's
big um calcium ions as
i mentioned or alluded
to act as secondary
messengers in many
pathways but if they're
excessive in the cell
they can cause injury
ischemia toxins can
cause an excessive
increase in the
calcium in the cell
because first
there's release from
intercellular stores and
later there's increased
influx across the
plasma membrane
so the calcium pump
fails this is not
good because you're
going to basically
activate enzymes,
and those enzymes are
going to damage
things. So the enzymes
include the four
listed here and others,
phospholipases,
proteases, and these
all cause damage to
the cell, which it
cannot survive,
okay, especially
endonucleases, which
will break down DNA.
This is necrosis
happening.
So on the left here
is a picture of what I
have been saying,
that's ischemia, there's
a blockage and it's um
oxidative phosphorylation
goes down and the
mitochondria remember
that's the uh the
workhouse uh atp goes
down and you have all
these consequences okay
um the big one on the
left is the reversible
one the sodium pump
and um the efl the
sodium going down
calcium will start
influxing but not till
later do the enzymes
get um activated so
then the anaerobic
glycolysis which decreases
the ph etc on the
right is the illustration
of the calcium
extracellular calcium
going intracellularly
not a good thing
because it activates
the enzymes and as
you can see from
the picture their
enzymes can when you
activate them they're
going to eat up things
like the membrane
and the nucleus and
that of course is
not good for the cell
one thing that they've
learned you know
again fine line
between reversible and
irreversible but
one thing that's
consistently found in
irreversible damage
is the inability to
reverse the mitochondrial
dysfunction you
don't have oxidative
phosphorylation
and atp generation
that and any
profound problem or
disturbance in the
membrane function
it these are
characteristic of necrosis
and that's where
we're going to
so cell injury now
we're talking about
necrosis which is
cell death this
is always a pathological
process okay
um the main causes
there are a lot of
causes but they're
listed here as like
ischemia is a big one
uh toxins burns etc
Necrosis is characterized
microscopically
by denaturation
of cellular
proteins which makes
things look pinker.
Leakage of cell
contents through
the membranes
that are damaged
and that inflammation
is elicited.
And of course
enzymatic cell dies and
digest itself
basically. Again that's
not autophagy. Autophagy
is when it does
it on purpose. This
is not on purpose.
when the cellular
contents leak out they
do elicit an inflammatory
response again
that will be the topic
of the next lecture
okay so we have a
picture here now we've
talked about what necrosis
is we have a picture
here of necrosis
okay but there's
different patterns
in necrosis different
morphological patterns on
the left here is normal
myocardium I don't
expect you to necessarily
recognize it but
But I hope you can
see left to right,
they're very different.
Right is a lot different
looking than the
left. And this is
ischemia of myocardium.
Look how really
bright pink-red the
cells are there on
the bottom of the
right hand picture
and the pycnosis
that's developing and
all this other stuff
that's developing
microscopically.
That is known as
coagulative necrosis. That's
one of the main patterns
of necrosis that
you should really
know. and in coagulant
necrosis the cell outlines
or the architecture
usually are preserved
at least for a while
but the nucleus is
gone it disappears.
There's also going to
be initially some really
pink red looking
cytoplasm because of the
denaturing of the
protein so you get
eosinophilia and when we
talk about a local area
of coagulant necrosis
we call that an infarct
such as a myocardial
effect this happens
in most organs that
are solid by solid I
don't mean the organ
has to be solid I mean
things like um you know
the kidney the liver
even in in the bladder
wall or you can have
ischemia in the intestines
obviously they're
not solid but the
the the wall is solid
so for the most part
coagulant necrosis
happens the other pattern
that can happen there's
four five patterns
is this pattern and
hopefully you recognize
in the top left this
is a what organ this is
a brain and something's
a little bit weird
with this brain
because it's got this
cavity that looks like
there's liquid in it
and it's all if you this
is mushy i know you
can't tell that by the
picture normally you
see what it looks like
on top those are you
know neurons microglia
etc but microscopically
what you're going
to see in the brain
is this on the bottom
which is a lot of white
space and a lot of
things eating up things
and and again I don't
expect you to recognize
but this is necrosis
this is not normal but
it's not collagative
necrosis it's known
as liquefactive
necrosis and really
this only happens in the
brain sometimes pancreas
in other places too
pancreas will talk
about fat necrosis as
well abscesses are a big
example of liquefactive
necrosis so you get
dead cells that are
digested and it results
in a very liquid
viscous mass neutrophils
release lysosomal
enzyme and then they
digest the tissue okay so
when you think of a
brain when we talked
about ****** that's
liquefactive necrosis this
is another type of
necrosis that you should
keep in mind um on the
bottom is the gross
picture on the top is
microscopic and you
see a really bland
pink middle area there
that doesn't look like
much of anything and
some big round cells
around it um and the
bottom i think i believe
that's lung tissue
whatever tissue it is
that big round nodule
is something known
as it's a chronic
inflammatory thing
known as a granuloma.
This is known as
caceous necrosis. Not
all granulomas are
caceous, but this
particular is caceous
necrosis. Caceous comes
from the word cheese
-like, because when
you looked at that
module, it was kind
of white, friable,
almost cheesy looking.
And when you see
the area under the
microscope, the granuloma,
you'll see basically
an amorphous area,
structureless collection
and it's enclosed by
a rim of macrophages
that are called
epithelioid because
they look a little bit
epithelial and a rim
of lymphocytes so it's
a nodular collection
and you can see
these as nodules when
they're big enough and
usually with caixous
necrosis we talk
about tuberculosis and
fungal infections
those are the two big
things to remember
about caixous necrosis
here's another picture
of it with the labels
um the necrosis look
you can't see anything
it's nothing it's
just pink stuff uh
the giant cells around
it and lymphocytes
okay another pattern 68
year old male alcoholic
presents with mid
-epigastric abdominal
pain and nausea he has
elevated amylase and
lipase level this man
is going through acute
pancreatitis and here
we're going to talk
about fatty necrosis now
in fatty necrosis you
have fat destruction
so you have release
of lipase which is an
enzyme that breaks down
fatty acids so the
peripancreatic fat
especially is going to get
dissolved basically and
that's fatty necrosis
another way the fatty
necrosis can occur is
trauma to the breast
for example trauma to
anything where there's
adipose tissue okay
um okay so the almost
the last type yeah
this is the last type
fibrinoid necrosis is
usually seen in vessel
damage that's caused by
immune reaction so you
get antigen antibody
deposits in the wall
as seen here and the
immune complexes combine
with fibrin and you
get this bright pink
uh you're going to notice
a lot of things are
bright pink and amorphous
looking and this
is usually a sign that
there's been a vascular
damage vasculitis
usually and we call this
fibrinoid necrosis
because it looks like
fiber and the pink stuff
i'm going to mention
gangrenous necrosis it's
not really a specific
pattern but i think
it should be mentioned
you guys have heard
of gangrene you know
people who have a
limb that's lost blood
supply and undergone
necrosis the skin the
muscle whatever even
the bone that's gangrene
but when you have bacterial
infection superimposed
on gangrene you're
going to get some
liquefactor necrosis
and you can get what's
known as wet gangrene
these are clinical terms
more rather than really
pathological okay
I would like to turn
to apoptosis which in
the past wasn't always
given that much time
but it's important to
know because apoptosis
is a different type of
cell death this is a
program type of cell
death it's tightly
regulated suicide program
so that the cells that
are destined to die
will activate intrinsic
enzymes known as
caspases that's important
to remember that
degrade cellular dna and
proteins so mechanism of
death here is regulated
this is not autophagy
because the cell
is destroying itself
not to save necessarily
because it's starved
okay this eliminates
cells that may be
irreparably damaged
etc and the big thing
are the caspases
the enzymes and you end
up with these things
called apoptotic
bodies that break up
into plasma membrane
brown fragments and
those have parts of
cytoplasma nucleus
in them. I want to
make a point that
apoptosis can be normal
or could be pathological
but necrosis is
always pathologic.
Let's talk about some
examples of normal
versus pathological
apoptosis this is just a
brief list here for
example when the embryo
is developing it has
webbed fingers and
webbed toes that area
has to go away the
webbed area so that's
that's normal that's
part of the normal uh
function and apoptosis
happens in the hormone
withdrawal involution
and menstruation and
in a human inflammatory
response pathological
that's really
important because when
there's DNA damage
you want to protect
yourself because that DNA
damage can lead to
cancer so apoptosis
occurs to get rid of
those damaged cells and
also in infections
and misfolded proteins
so this is just a little
bit more and again
it looks like a lot of
words but this slide
and the next this
is on physiological
apoptosis and the next
one's on pathological
I just want to emphasize
that physiological
apoptosis is normal
to eliminate cells
that aren't needed or
to maintain a constant
number of cells and
tissues and there
there are one two
three four five six
bullet points here
of things that can be
considered physiologic
apoptosis I already
talked about supernumerary
cells too many
that have to be removed
during development
the menstrual cycle,
cell turnover,
big things, elimination
of lymphocytes
that don't produce
functional antigens.
So for example,
immature lymphocytes
in the low marrow
and pharma and
general center B
cells, they have to
become apoptotic or
things will go bad.
And for elimination
of harmful cell for
reactive lymphocytes. So
you know, autoimmunity,
you don't want
autoimmune diseases
and that's why apoptosis
can be important.
it's also important
for the death of
host cells um that
already did their job
like neutrophils in
the acute inflammatory
response or
lymphocytes in the
immune response um
the the thing with um
the physiological
apoptosis cancer and we'll
learn about this in a
couple more lectures
it can happen when
apoptosis is blocked
because it cannot get
rid of the damaged cell
and so the damaged
cell survives so that's
something for the
future to think about.
Pathologically the
apoptosis eliminates
cells that are
injured beyond repair
again it's in a
protective effect by
preventing survival
of cells with DNA
mutations that can go
on to be malignant.
Other things like
misfolded proteins
certain infections
um remember that
immunologically
speaking important host
response to viruses
are that the
cytotactic key lymphocytes
the ctls specific
for viral proteins
induce apoptosis
of the infected
cells because they
want to get rid of
the infection that
happens also it
is responsible for
killing tumor so if
you block apoptosis
that's going to
be a problem okay
so what does it look
like how is it different
than necrosis well
they both have pygnosis
and cariexis but
and and yes this the
cytoplasm is pink but
the cell it shrinks and
there's membrane
blubbing and I have a
comparison picture coming
up there is no elicited
inflammation and
that's very important
because you want to
limit damage in apoptosis
so yes phagocytes
come in and phagocytes
the apoptotic bodies but
there's no neutrophils
this is an example
of an apoptotic body
it's very dark and
dense and it could be
in any place this
happens to be in the skin
and the mechanisms
involved are very complex
and I don't need you
to know them in detail
I do want you to
remember that it's done
by enzymes called
caspases that initially
caspases get activated
and then cause a cascade
of other caspases and
then the execution
phase is the terminal
caspase the last one
that will cause the
cellular fragmentation.
All of this is regulated
by pro and anti
-apoptotic proteins.
There has to be a balance
and we'll talk a little
bit about that and
there are two distinct
pathways that converge
on the caspase
activation and I want to
talk a little bit
about those but again i
don't need you to know
them in exquisite detail
although somebody else
may the mitochondrial
pathway and the death
receptor pathway
these pathways will
intersect but generally
they are induced by
different conditions etc
so in the intrinsic
mitochondrial pathway
here are a lot of words
but what do i want
you to know this
results from increased
permeability of the
mitochondrial outer membrane
and so what happens is
pro-apoptotic molecules
are released um one
example they give
is cytochrome c and so
when apoptosis happens
it leads to these pro
-apoptotic proteins
leaving um and caspase
activation anti-apoptotic
proteins include
members of the bcl2
family which we'll talk
about at another time
um and this change of
proportion where you
have more pro-apoptotic
versus anti will lead
to apoptosis again
the important things
here are mitochondrial
permeability and cytochrome
c release if you
remember anything from
the slide is that
the um the intrinsic
mitochondrial pathway
is caspase 9 that's the
enzyme it's the critical
initiator you need
that to be initiated
it's initiated there's
an apoptosome this
form by interaction I
mentioned cytochrome c
and these other things
that you do not need
to memorize now the
extrinsic or the death
receptor which sounds
like death star pathway
is initiated by engaging
the plasma membrane
death receptors
what's a death receptor
they're members of the
tumor necrosis factor
receptor family they
have a domain in the
cytoplasm that involves
protein protein
interactions these are death
domains that you need
to deliver signals for
apoptosis the best
known one the best
described is the FAS
related protein FAS it's in
the book in excruciating
detail that I'm not
going to go into the
extrinsic apoptosis
pathway can be inhibited
as well by something
called a flip protein
the death receptor
pathway really is
is important because
it eliminates
self-reactive
lymphocytes and is a
mechanism for cell
killing by cytotoxic
t lymphocytes
so now the intrinsic
and the extrinsic
pathways converge and
you get activation of
the of the executioner
you know so you've got
the caspase 9 but the
extrinsic is caspase
8 or 10 and that forms
you know this uh the
executioner caspases
which are 3 and 6. again
you don't need to know
the numbers so nine
just remember is the
intrinsic but it's a
whole cascade nine
is important for the
initiation and then finally
we got a cascade and
we become we need to
get rid of all these
enzymes are breaking
these downs you need to
get rid of the dead
cells that you put into
bite-sized fragments
the apoptotic bodies and
sometimes those bodies
and we'll learn this
in information as well
they get coated with
antibodies in this
examples include some of
the complement system
and those antibodies
make them more susceptible
to being phagocytose
so they're and I thought
I made this up but
there are eight me
signals apparently the
book uses this term too
it's kind of like and
I don't know why I saw
we do this but it's
like telling it here
I am I'm going to you
know I'm right here
this is my signal and
please phagocytose this
again is a visual of
everything I just said
a little bit of detail
more maybe but if you
are more visual learner
i think this is very
nice this is also a
visual of necrosis next
to apoptosis and what's
going on and the
differences i would look
at this slide again
you don't have to know
every single detail but
it's a good overview
and this i like because
it's a cartoon form
but it shows the
differences between necrosis
and apoptosis in the way
it looks microscopically
so there's cell
shrinkage in apoptosis
that does not happen
in necrosis that's cell
swelling there's
chromatin condensation
which is very characteristic
of apoptosis where
the chromatin aggregates
peripherally under
the nuclear membrane
and get these dense
masses and the formation
of cytoplasmic blebs
and apoptotic bodies
that's under apoptosis
and then all the way
on the bottom is the
phagocytosis by
macrophages but there's no
inflammatory response
meaning there's
no neutrophils
coming in and that
limits the damage to
other tissue around
okay so follow this look
down the side these
are the differences and
the similarities I
get this out this is
another slide which I'm
putting up for just for
your benefit just for
to put away back in
your mind these are
new mechanisms of cell
death that have been
described in the past five
years they're still
being worked out and
they include things
called necroptasis,
pyroptasis, and phyroptasis.
You can read this.
I'm not going to hold
you accountable to this
myself. I don't know
if anybody else would.
Okay, finally, we
got to cellular
accumulations. Why do
cells accumulate things?
Why? And how is that
pathology? Well, if
you have inadequate
removal of substances
or accumulation of
endogenous substances
or failure to degrade
substances etc or
deposition of abnormal
substances exogenously
these will all
cause cellular
accumulations and there's
a lot of them I want
to mention lipid protein
pigments and live
diffusion and I've
got pictures of them
lipid an example
would be steatosis
of the liver or
fatty liver this
is a reversible
cell injury but
it is seen when
fats accumulate.
Protein accumulation, an
example would be amyloid.
Pigments, there's
all different kinds.
There's coal, there's
melanin, I should say
carbon, anthracosis,
melanin, hemocytorin,
lipofusion. What
is lipofusion? It's
known as a wear and
tear pigment. If you
look at a lot of,
I've done autopsies on
elderly people, a
lot of their um their
cells in the heart
or the kidney or the
liver will have this
golden brown pigment
and that is a wear and
tear pigment it shows
you that it's been
around a while and um
it's you know this is
part of normal uh process
of aging although it is
a cellular accumulation
that you have to look
at as a pathologist
because it could be
mistaken for others
and you'll see what i
mean and the top is the
liver with big holes
in it those holes are
fat that's fatty liver
on the right is amyloid
which is like a pink
glassy looking um
kind of look to it
you have to do special
stains to really diagnose
that don't worry um
on the bottom is the
lipofusion if you see in
the cardiac it's very
very very light golden
brown whereas in the
liver it looks very
dark and that's a
problem because the liver
also has bile it could
have hemorrhage and all
those things could
look like that so you
got to be aware of that
anthracosis is carbon
this happens to be a
very close-up picture
of a lung which shows
black lines you probably
saw this in your um
in your cadavers the
important part of this
is that anybody who
smokes or anybody living
in a city would probably
have some of this
smokers even worse on
the bottom we have melanin
and then hemocytron
is broken down blood
so this happens to
be in lung alveoli
because this is somebody
with congestive heart
failure blood backed up
into the lung and
macrophages so there's all
it's evidence of old
hemorrhage or old blood
okay a really quick
thing about hyaline
change you'll it's not
hyaline cartilage again
it's a pink glassy
look and it's more of a
of a descriptive
thing there is finally
pathological calcification
meaning there are you
can see calcification
in certain tissues
and that's not normal um
it could be dystrophic
or metastatic dystrophic
means the person
has a normal serum
calcium but it's the area
that's being calcified
is damaged so what
an example of that would
be uh cardiac valves
which get calcified
sometimes is because of
damage and so it's
calcium deposition on
abnormal tissue whereas
metastatic calcification
which has no specific
relationship to
malignancy i don't like
the term the tissue is
normal but the person
has hypercalcemia four
major causes include
those mentioned there
hyperparathyroidism
vitamin d disorders
etc and you can see
this especially in the
kidney and lung gastric
mucosa so here's
a picture of distrosive
calcification up
on top left it's very
blue purple that's
the color of
calcification also it's
crunchy if there's
a lot of it and the
metastatic one in the
lung has not to do with
cancer but the person
had hypercalcemia
so this is the
summary slide and
I know I went a
little bit over
I thank you for
your attention
and if you have
any questions,
please reach out
to me. Thank you.